prénom prénom du fils attention sur le
bout comment se prénomme le fils alors
sur le grotesque de Paris Hilton
Martinez Roissy Orly Phoenix sous London
pourquoi parce que c'est le nom d'une
ville comme elle non parce qu'il a été
construit à Phoenix
et il y a un truc que j'aimerais faire
mais même un sujet c'est pas une photo
ouais alors pourquoi quand on est star
il faut toujours parce qu'on est star on
se balade pas avec un chien mais avec un
tigre avec un lion un crocodile un port
comme George Clooney qui s'appelle
lourdet on a toujours une fille ou un
fils qui a un prénom que personne n'a
parce qu'on est des stars alors il y a
des prénoms je vous les donne c'est
tellement ridicule non parce qu'elle
était dans le Nord
Brooklyn alors ceux de Brad Pitt que
j'adore mais que la coiffure Shilo
nouvelle Madoc Shivan Vivienne Marceline
et knock Knox
c'est vrai on dirait une ordonnée alors
le pire le pire le pire c'est elon must
Elon Musk pour moi il est en train de il
est en train de briller complètement
complètement
d'argent et quand on a beaucoup d'argent
et qu'on est fou on peut être dangereux
il a appelé son fils
xaea 12 mais vous savez mais comme ça
dis-moi ce qui s'est passé
xaea très enfin X1 pour faire 12 en
chiffre romain mais sauf que c'est
interdit d'avoir des caractères en
dehors d'avoir des des gaufres le 12 là
on n'a pas le droit dans la loi
américaine c'est la seule le seul truc
qu'on a pas le droit donc du coup il a
dû le changer et mettre en chiffre
Romains X11 pour faire un incroyable
parce qu'il faut savoir que juste pour
les les États-Unis il y a aucune noire
qui enquête les prénoms d'enfants alors
peut-être un petit peu si tu l'appelles
éclair ou quoi mais tu peux l'appeler
table rideaux est-ce que tu veux et tu
as le droit de l'entourer dans un
torchon ton fils aussi voilà
il faut choisir il faut choisir parmi
une liste qu'on te donne
en France depuis 94 13 tu peux choisir
mais si la mairie décide que c'est pas
bon pour lui là encore une fois tu
l'appelles Adolf il faut que la vie va
être continue ils peuvent te dire non
en Allemagne les noms doivent être
approuvés tu envoies le nom t'attends 2
jours on la prouve et surtout il faut
qu'il montre le sexe de la personne
c'est à dire qu'on a une fille
apparaître avec Michel en Allemagne
alors attendez euh
ça va pour les deux en même temps j'ai
une question moi j'ai une question
est-ce que la loi autorise si toutefois
emporte le prénom d'un grand criminel
qui va arriver qui n'a pas encore eu
lieu on a le droit de le changer oui on
a bien sûr
on peut changer de nom de famille